okay we will start with three three six
before going to today
[Music]
this you look very surprised on the
stage when your name was called this was
amazing to win like this is you have
four Oscars now for the movie so far so
what's your reaction to having one and
if you can answer in German that would
be great
foreign
[Music]
All Quiet on the Western Front was a
team effort all the way through
and would you kindly
um repeat your answer in English sure
if I can remember that we all know that
the Oscar is heavy I think we got that
part okay thank you so much
um no I was just saying that the um
after the your name is called
the those 25 or 30 steps on stage
are like moonwalking you basically
forget everything that was in your head
and the moment you hit the microphone
you just
you just don't know it anymore but
suddenly you remember when you're up
there that it was a team effort and we
could have not done it with all those
other beautiful people at all quiet at
the Western Front it was a real team
effort
there was a war before the camera there
was no war behind the camera
teen on death hello
do you have a message to the fans back
home and who do you call first now
[Music]
German or anything
um
well I guess my father is going to be 90
soon so I will call them first of course
because
you know parents are
this is something you know they started
this anyways
and
um I want to thank you know especially
all of my teams it's it's been a 40 Euro
long walk
from back there on this stage and I
really mean it
um you're only good as your team and you
have if you have people supporting you
and understanding you and helping you
and we are our departmental hard workers
and I mean if you
look at that movie
we spend a lot of time in dirt and mud
and you have to have people supporting
you
and on top of it
it was an extremely wonderful experience
for me because
when I when we started this we were like
we don't want to go into war you know
and it was just the opposite because
every Department there were Masters and
extremely
well-centered people working and we all
it all became a an incredibly loving
crew supporting each other
and I truly believe that this energy is
now even if you know the story is as it
is it transported it into the audience
and that's my belief that's what we hear
and thank you
okay we have number 218 followed by 360
I believe number 360 can you raise your
number up so they can get the microphone
to you hello my name is Thomas buscale
from the Slovak Republic for television
uh Joy joj Czech Republic was really
involved also in the movie so I feel
kind of as a friend from the neighboring
company Slovakia what yes I'm so happy
for you guys it's so amazing what were
the first steps of making and creating
such an incredible uh World of War
this is a simple and straight answer
it's research
so it's a it's digging deep into the
archives we we went to Belgium France
South Germany we didn't you know
particularly visited national museums we
um
we researched it and only if you dig
deep into what there is or what there
was then you can
replicated and
that's what we try to do we
um
try to move away from propaganda because
propaganda beautify War would have been
propaganda and we try to make it as real
as possible
and said something against
nationalism
first of all
not knowing that there was a war coming
after that thanks
may you say one more thing please I'm
sure you can say whatever you want um
I personally
um
you know the Czech people
they wouldn't this movie wouldn't have
been without them and without the
locations and without you know because
you find
Christian found the locations they were
fitting
this this script
in Czech Republic and I couldn't I've
even imagined a different another place
than that
and the people are very incredible with
crafts and they have a huge heart and
they work hard you know
and they thank all of them we thank all
of them for that because that made the
miracle happen thank you
okay and our final question number 360.
yes it's not because they were built
Germany uh just um now it's four Oscars
for this beautiful terrible Beautiful
film
what will it change in your uh if it's
your crew with with the director with
it's um what is the secret of the
success
that's very easy to answer I mean
because Edward Berger in the beginning
of the movie he just like basically had
a little speech to everybody and saying
okay let's do this
let's not fight
let's take each other's hands
and let's walk through there no
lamenting no fighting not allowed not on
this project and we did this on the
height of covet there was no
vaccinations nothing we we really took
care for each other
possibly there wasn't any party and no
drinking going on either so
um
so no the the thing is all quiet
became the movie it is now because of a
immense team effort and team support we
don't do movies very often where there's
no fighting going on behind the camera
in this one there was Zero of it
it was a collaboration
all the way through
thank you
so much and congratulations
foreign